alright the lego movie was a
surprisingly good movie so now we have
lego batman oh my god my hand oh hi
ha ha oh what's wrong with me the lego
batman movie alright there's a change me
back you just can't happen the whole
time this review would take a year to do
in lego so it's not going to change me
back oh god baby I wasn't no that was it
that is never happened to me before
so the Lego Batman movie is ultimately a
spinoff from the lego movie
so now Lego Batman has his own movie
cleverly titled the Lego Batman movie
and in the Lego Batman movie you have
Lego Batman who is a real narcissist
this particular Batman's like if Ron
Burgundy and Batman had a kid he thinks
he's super awesome he doesn't care about
anyone the Joker has his plan he's going
to devastate Gotham Joker voiced by Zach
Galifianakis which is funny because if
you count Mark Hamill's Joker for master
the phantasm which was a theatrically
released film Zach Galifianakis is the
fourth best on-screen Joker he didn't
have to mail dead rats and condoms to
people it is that simple just perform
but I hated Jared Leto's Joker why'd you
send it funny when I walked out of Lego
Batman I was like a little Leto's Joker
is number 5 that is the thing for me so
what the Batman references and meta
humor begin because now we have Lego
Batman movie see what this movie is is a
very effective spoof movie to spoof
comedy which is funny because not too
long ago in a video I said something
along the lines of the time of good
spoof comedies is dead and behind us
there was a time now we are no longer in
that time because spoof comedies
generally speaking sucks that like a
Batman comes out and like oh you could
still do that but this movie has going
forward is the property of Batman I mean
Batman alone if you look at all the
films has a lot of jokes and a lot of
characters you can pull from it or if
you look at the comic books there's a
lot of jokes and a lot of property you
can pull from it point is they're going
to tap a resource this is the ideal one
to tap a resource and make a spoof out
it which is funny because this is an
effectively great Batman movie and it
didn't have director problems or writer
problems or script rewrites already the
DC Cinematic Universe that we're
dealing with right now it just they made
it and it's good the intro to this movie
alone had me
I was sitting back in the theater chair
laughing my eyes are going okay so
that's how this movie's going to be
energized man and that's the thing the
movie is it's very high energy there's
clip after clip after clip after line
after line up to joke after joke which
is the movies greatest strength but also
kind of a weakness because it is
exhausting kind of an hour into this
movie or like this movie hasn't stopped
at all an hour into the movie you
realize the movie takes a bit of a dip
it's a shocking dip because the first
half-hour is so high energy and then
when the movie kind of slows down - the
whole family dynamic you're like oh okay
we're here very sharp turn you just made
but slowing down like that however the
family dynamic is a strong element in
the story as a whole so it does work
basically if you're a fan of Batman
Batman movies or movies in general
there's enough humor in here to keep you
engaged and occupied I think you're
really going to dig this one the movie
takes necessary jabs at the property and
even to self-deprecating humor of recent
films and there's something special when
the studio can be like yeah we can make
fun of that and the lego style of
stop-motion animation I think it's great
something daring about it it's great
seeing everything's being constructed
with Legos we saw that in the lego movie
now we see in the Lego Batman movie it's
great as the case is with Legos this
movie is limited only by imagination and
film property there's that but keep your
eyes and ears peeled in this one there
are visual references as well as some
soundtrack references if you're
listening to the music like when ever
was going nuts to Pokemon go I hope you
catch them all so lego batman movie was
sharp it was funny like really funny as
a movie fan it hit me where it needed to
hit me I dug it entirely drink your Red
Bull because when this movie is going it
doesn't stop it doesn't take a price you
need to keep up with it I will say the
Lego Batman movie is definitely worth
watching and definitely worth buying on
blu-ray or 4k or digital download or
whatever the kids are doing these days
to watch movies alright guys so the Lego
Batman movie have you seen it what did
you think about it how does it compare
to the lego movie which one's better
lego movie or lego batman whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and special thank you the lord of
the bricks for doing the intro of this
video that was really cool totally
kicked ideas a good job dude if you
haven't seen videos by lord of the
brig's you does have a youtube channel
where he does a lot of lego videos and
lego starwars fun this just like that
i'll put a link of his channel below so
you can go check it out support him
support your local youtube talent and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you
[Music]